Let's begin with our prayer before study.
Lord Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God
to place my absolute nothingness in the heart of the most holy trinity,
to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my existence
by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God.
And in this same manner, may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires,
and may you, my beloved divine will, do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately
that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure,
and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will
that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me.
Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary,
to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light,
so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers.
Amen. We're going to begin tonight with March the 28th, 19, 26,
and we have some wonderful messages from the Lord tonight.
So, Louisa begins having received Holy Communion.
I was calling everyone, my sweet mother and the saints.
I was calling the first Adam and the retinue of all generations up to the last man
who will come upon the earth and then all created things so that all together prostrate with me
around Jesus we might adore him bless him and love him.
Now notice in praying in the divine will you don't go alone.
You bring all heaven with you and you bring everybody from Adam to Zachary with you as well.
We put our arms around the entire human race and we love them all into the presence of God
and we do what we can in the divine will to substitute for them,
to make reparation for them, to offer them to the Lord in every possible way.
It's really beautiful. So she said so that nothing might be missing around Jesus.
Now notice her concern is Jesus. All of this she's doing because she loves him
and because if she loves him then she knows that Jesus deserves everything.
He has paid for everybody. He has paid for the redemption of everybody.
He deserves everything and she wants him to have everything.
And I think that taking that approach to interceding for others is actually very interesting
because you will persevere for his sake even if you don't like the people you're praying for
which is very interesting because we have to pray for people whether they are considered
enemies or friends because in the divine will we don't have enemies except the demons.
St Paul said that in Ephesians chapter 6 our enemies are not flesh and blood.
So she's concerned about Jesus so that nothing might be missing around Jesus of all the works
which came out of his hands, not a heart that palpitates, nor a sun that shines, nor the vastness
of the blue heavens studded with stars, nor the sea that murmurs, and not even the tiny little
flower that gives off its fragrance. She wants absolutely everything around him.
I wanted, she said, to centralize everything and everyone around Jesus host.
I think this is terribly important in this new era that we're moving into.
Jesus will be reigning from the Tabernacle. It is Jesus host that will be reigning upon the earth.
He won't be coming back physically as some denominations seem to think.
God never has to repeat anything twice ever but there would be no point in coming back physically
if he's to reign for this entire millennium anyway. So she wants to centralize everything
around Jesus host. Now her instinct to do in this prayer is what the church will be doing
in that new era, absolutely bringing the whole earth and all of the heavens and everything
around Jesus. Jesus will truly be Lord. That'll be a most wonderful thing. So that we might render
him the honors due to him and make reparation, of course, for all the past when it wasn't
given to him. His will made everything present for me, she said, as if everything were mine
and I wanted to give everything to Jesus. Now because Louisa is the first and therefore the one
that the Lord wants to use to open the new era to us, he allows her to actually see,
to perceive in her mind this whole reality. It's not necessary for us to be able to see it.
Once we know that it's a reality, we just make the offering anyway. So while I was doing this,
she said, it seemed to me that Jesus was happy in looking at all generations and of all the things
around himself. One of the things I like to do is I like to do it last thing at night before I
close my eyes. When I pray for all the generations is to bring them to him on the cross so that his
dying eyes can actually see the fruits of his labors, just as a little moment of consolation to him
in those dying moments. That's the instinct that Louisa has to offer him the comfort and the
consolation that she possibly can offer to him. But you need to be thinking of him all the time
to do this kind of thing. If you're just into making official prayers, you won't have this
personal response. And it's this personal response to Jesus that I've been saying to you over the
years that Jesus actually wants. You can see the most wonderful prayers that other people have
written and they are fine. But one tiny little one coming straight out of your being to him is
infinitely better in my opinion. And if we all do that, then he gets the variety that he's looking
for that I've been telling you about down the years. He needs this variety. In other words, in a
wonderful painting, if you look at one of the great master paintings, and you'll find all kinds of
subteams and different colors, and it's really fantastic what the painter can put into just one
canvas. If you look at one little corner, you might be just looking at a garden full of the most
beautiful flowers. In another corner, you'll be looking at a magnificent sky. And that's quite
a part from the main theme that he's actually painting. Well, I think in the whole vast scheme
of things, Jesus wants these subplots as well, because it adds to the beauty and glory of the
response that the human race really needs to give him. So he was looking at all the generations,
and he was pleased with it. And so she says he'd classed me to himself. And that's very official
language. Let's use ordinary English. He gave me a hug. And he told me, my daughter, how content I
am in seeing all of my works around me. So he likes us to bring everything around him. I feel
I am given back the joy and the happiness which I gave to them in creating them. Now, notice it's
the return of love all the time. Love goes out from God as the creator. Everything is created
out of love and sent out into being with lovers that main ingredient in us. And that love must go
back to him to complete the cycle of love. Otherwise, the creation isn't complete. So I feel I'm given
back the joy and the happiness which I gave to them and then creating them. And I repay them with new
happiness. So it starts another cycle of loving and giving on his part. So this is the great good
which my will contains and brings. And in one who lives in it, now a question I got last week was,
what exactly do you mean by living in it? And I'll give you an answer to help you to think about it.
And if you want to come back with the response after the class, or privately, that's absolutely
fine by me. My response was, I think I'm living in the divine will when I give him every thought,
every word, every action, every movement, every motivation, every desire, everything.
When I'm holding nothing back, I'm really living in the divine will. I'm swimming in water when I
plunge myself into it and there's water everywhere. So he has to be everything to us. To me, that's
living in the divine will, but your response would be interesting to me. So the great good
which my will contains and brings. And so this is it. And in one who lives in the divine will,
the divine will centralizes the goods of all. Notice what he's saying. She started out by wanting to
centralize absolutely everything in Jesus. That's where it starts. So he turns around then and he says
that if a person is truly living in the divine will, that the divine will or God himself centralizes
the goods of all in that person. Because there is no good which my will does not bring. It's the source
of all good. And the divine will binds the soul to everyone and to everything that belongs to it.
Therefore, here is another little key to testing how far am I into the divine will. And that is,
this is a universal response to God and to the human race. Literally, nobody is left out. It's
love without boundaries. Because that's who Jesus is love without boundaries. And so you can't be
holding on to political prejudices or religious prejudices or racial prejudices or any other
prejudice that they're talking about. That is completely outside of this completely. You have to
embrace absolutely everybody regardless of whether they have religion or not. Whether they are
persecutors or saints, you embrace them all. If Jesus embraced the lepers and he embraced the
sinners and he embraced absolutely everybody. And he loved his enemies as much as he loved the others.
Because in the divine will, human beings not your enemy. Our enemies are not flesh and blood. They
are the powers of darkness in high places. That's enough flesh and blood. And so we have the instinct
in the divine will to bring as many human beings back into that circle of love and into the fullness
of that circle of love. So in the divine will, you are an evangelizer. You are somebody who is out there
looking for souls. So if you're not there in your relationship with God, then realize that you haven't
gone very far into the divine will. Because if we're truly, truly, truly looking at God,
he gets us to look at our neighbor. Because they're the two sides of the commandment,
to love God and to love your neighbor. And your neighbor is every human being on the planet.
So the divine will binds the soul to everyone and to everything. So while the non-believers are
talking about their worship of Gaia Mother Earth, it is actually the people in the divine will who
love the earth correctly and who want everything to be centralized around its creator and for
everything to come into the divine order. It binds the soul to everyone and to everything
that belongs to it because everything belongs to God, the creator. So if the creature had not
withdrawn from my will, Jesus said, I would have found everyone within everyone. In other words,
our love would have embraced everyone. And this is what he wants when we come back into the divine
will that he will find everyone in you. I would have found everyone within each one and each one
in everyone. Now there's your John 15 nine. As the father has loved me, so I have loved you,
so you are to love each other. So we have to love each other with the divine love that the father
loved his son. This is what we're talking about. The goods, the light, the strength, the knowledge,
the love, the beauty were all to be in common. So we wouldn't have this terrible rivalry
and someone climbing over somebody else to get to the top. That would be impossible.
There was to be neither yours nor mine. This is true socialism.
Either both in the natural and in the spiritual order. Each one could have taken as much as he
wanted, just as he tells us so frequently that with the sun in the sky, each one of us can have
as much sun as we want to. And today we probably had more than we had in a long time, but you're
not taking it from anybody else in having as much as you want. And that's the incredible thing about
this extraordinary unity that is not only among the three divine persons, but that unity that is
between them and each individual soul living in the divine will, and therefore all of these souls
living in the divine will have this extraordinary unity between them. Haven't you noticed that all
of us in the divine will classes, for example, that we feel we have a bond with each other,
that we don't have with other people, that there's an all-traumatic recognition
of family? It's there. It's actually very noticeable in the divine will groups.
And so it's this recognition of this extraordinary relationship that's going on inside of us.
So Jesus continues then and he says that the sun is actually a symbol for us, as he frequently
says. "The human life in my will was to be symbolized by the sun. Everyone can take its light,
and as much as they want, without anyone else lacking it. However, as man withdrew from my will,
the goods, the light, the strength, the love, the beauty remain divided, and as though have
among creatures." So notice the divide and conquer that Satan uses. Once we remain divided, Satan can
get in and do his terrible damage. When we're in the divine will, there's this extraordinary unity
and recognition of unity. Therefore, since this has happened, there's no more order, there's no
harmony, there's no true love. If there's anything we would recognize today on the earth, there certainly
isn't true love. There are many people actually living in the same house claiming to be partners
or married or whatever, and they probably don't know what love is at all. It's extraordinary. Love
has grown cold today, which is one of the signs of the end times. But when you come back into the
divine order, and you come back into this extraordinary relationship with God through the divine will,
love returns. Harmony comes back. Divine order comes back. Wholeness comes back.
And so your whole being, body, soul, and spirit is gradually transformed so that people can recognize
that something has actually happened to you. Or if the sun could be divided into many rays,
watch this now. This is very interesting. These solar rays detaching from the center of light
would end up becoming darkness. That is exactly what happened to Lucifer. God is light. That is
one John one five. God is light in him. There is no darkness. And so when Lucifer, one of the highest
angels in heaven, awfully glorious, moved away from that light, that automatically meant going
into darkness. And so when human beings move away from the divine will, as we see society today
doing, you see the darkness coming upon society. And the more people will move away from that center,
the more darkness will come upon society. And people will no longer be able to see spiritually.
And they won't be able to see here or understand spiritual things at all. It'll be very frightening.
It's getting very close to that. And he says, and what would happen to the earth if this happens?
Indeed, no one would ever again have a light of his own all for himself. So it was with my will,
by withdrawing from it, man lost the fullness of the goods, the fullness of light, the fullness
of strength, the fullness of beauty, etc. And therefore he was forced to live a light of hardship.
So now you know why life is difficult. Therefore be attentive, he said, like you're living in my will
be continuous. Now continuous is every nano second of every day. There are no minutes off. There's no
such thing as five minutes off from the divine will, you're either in there, like the fish in the ocean
totally and completely submerged in the ocean. It must be continuous so that you can contain
everything. You see, we won't be able to either hold the things that the Lord has given to us.
We won't be able to do it if we're not living continuously in the divine will. And this is the
only way that he can find everything in us and everyone as well. So the extraordinary thing is
that instead of continuing this discussion with Jesus, Louisa breaks off and goes into a new topic.
And so she asks Jesus a question. And that is, you know, since the blessed mother had absolutely
everything given to her and she was in the divine will from the first instance of her being,
why didn't she pray for the Viet Vellon test to on earth as in heaven? So that's what she's thinking.
And really in thinking that Louisa is sort of saying, why did you wait? And then to start all
this length of time, to start it with me. So Louisa said, if the true living in the Supreme
will contain so much good, why did my celestial mother, who was all will of God, not pray the
Viet Vellon test to on earth as in heaven together with the longed fur Redeemer? So as to let man
return to the Supreme Fiat from which he came to give back to him all the goods and the purpose
for which he was created. So why didn't she do the two together? Why did she just pray for the Redeemer
and not pray for the Fiat? Okay, well, the third Fiat. So more so since being all will of God,
she had no nourishment extraneous to God. This is very interesting. Because of the depth that she
was living in the divine will, there was nothing coming in from the world to feed her. There was
nothing coming in from the self to feed her. There was no block in her person. There was no block
in anything that was coming from the world. She was completely and totally forgot. And since that
was so, she possessed the very divine power and with it, she could have interceded for anything.
And she was right, Louise is right in her thinking. So my sweet Jesus moving again in my interior side
and he said, my daughter, the primary purpose of all that my mother did and of all that I did in
redemption was that my Fiat would reign on the earth. That was what God wanted to do, but she's
now going to say, well, we had to take certain steps to get to that point. It would not have been
right, nor a true love, nor a great generosity and even less an operating worthy of the God that I was.
If in coming into the world, I had given and wanted to give the creatures the smaller things,
which was the means to be saved, but not the greater one, which was my will. Now, what he's saying to her
is actually redemption is smaller than the divine will naturally enough because people have lived in
it for centuries, for two millennia. And even when they reach sanctity, they've not reached
this level of divine will that we're actually talking about. Okay. And you would like to have
given the greater one first, but we're not ready. In the same way, you bring a child to school when
they're four years of age, are you going to teach them trigonometry? Are you going to teach them
astrophysics? Of course, you're not. You're going to teach them how to read and write first.
So redemption, which contains not only the remedies, but all possible goods that exist in heaven and
on earth, not only salvation and sanctity, but that sanctity, which raises them to the very
sanctity of their creator. That is the way we have to look at that we're looking at the highest
possible level of sanctity available to the human being. And of course, it's going to say to her,
look, we had to take it in steps. People weren't ready. And you can see from reading the gospel
that they weren't ready even for what Jesus wanted to do in redemption. Oh, if you could penetrate
into each prayer, each act and each word and each pain of my inseparable mother, you would find in
them the fiat which she longed for and prayed for. It was there. That's like saying, a mother is
praying for her child and wants the absolute highest and best for her child, but she still has to send
the child to primary school. And then the child has to go to the next school. And then the child
has to go to the next school. They've got to go from ABC to the top. It can't just give them the top
first. So but the fiat was there. If you could penetrate into each drop of my blood, he said,
in each one of my heartbeats, breath, steps, work, sorrows and tears, you would find the fiat having
primacy in them, which I longed and asked for for creatures because everything had to be interceded
for at the time of redemption. But while the primary purpose was the fiat, my goodness had to descend
to the secondary purpose and act almost like a teacher. I don't know why he says almost because
he's so much a teacher in the gospel who though possessing the highest knowledge and being able
to give noble and sublime lessons worthy of himself, but since his students are so illiterate,
had to lower himself to giving the lessons in ABC, to then be able to reach little by little
his primary purpose of imparting the lessons in the knowledge that he possesses and to make of them
as many teachers worthy of such a teacher. Now to me, that sentence is a most wonderful reflection
on the training of the apostles during the time of Jesus' ministry. He had to start at the very
beginning with them. I mean, after all, he took some fishermen from the sea who hadn't had any
learning and he had to take them from the very beginning. And what he achieved was unbelievable.
Now notice he used apprenticeship with them, that they walked with him, they shared his life,
and he was able to explain things as they went along. And so they had the whole example of the way he
lived his teaching as well. And so when we're training teachers, they have to be able to see
in us a life lived as well. And you know, teachers make teachers. It's actually very important.
So if this teacher did not want to lower himself to give lessons in inferior studies,
I wanted to give lessons in the higher science than the students being illiterate would not have
understood him and confused by such great knowledge, which they ignored, they would leave him.
Okay, so you try to teach trigonometry then to a four year old and they'll go away from you
and play with their adults on the floor. Okay, so a teacher must understand the student and must
understand the needs of the student and no matter what you know about divine will, if your students
are at the first level, you give them first level. You're not actually honoring them by giving them
the tenth level. That's why I've never agreed with beginning reading Louisa Pricaretta's writings
at volume 12, when Jesus had gone to the trouble of revealing 11 volumes before that, all of which
are full of incredible divine knowledge and understanding. We have to take, this is a journey,
we can't just jump into it, presuming we're ready, we're not ready. We've got to take it step by step.
And those of you who have been in the divine will for a number of years, you know it's a journey
and you know that going back to the early volumes, you can still go back and get it as fresh as
anything again. So we have to take the students step by step and that's what Jesus did in the gospel.
And the incredible thing is that the same Peter who said to Jesus, "No to suffering."
The same man when he had been through his training, been through his suffering and
being through his trials and all the rest of it, he laid down his life for his master.
The lessons only come slowly. And so it's not right for us to think that we can jump from lesson
one to lesson ten. I think that's a presumption. So if the teacher did not want to lower himself
to give lessons in inferior studies and wanted to give lessons in the higher science, the students
being illiterate wouldn't understand him and would go off. And the poor teacher not wanting to lower
himself would give neither the small good nor the great good. It's very very interesting,
it'd end up actually giving nothing. And so he tells us in the next paragraph, start at the
beginning and work your way off. Now those of you who are teachers, please take this on board.
Now my daughter, when I came upon the earth, creatures were all illiterate in the things of
heaven. And you know a person can have a university degree in something or other and be completely
illiterate in spiritual things. So they were all illiterate. And if I had wanted to speak about the
fiat and the true living in the divine will, they would have been incapable of understanding.
Since they did not know the way to come to me, even though the Psalms are full of the request,
Lord, teach us your ways. And I want to give you one example. Psalm 86, 11, I could give you many.
It's all over the Psalms. Lord, teach us your ways. And Jesus told us in John 14, 6, I am the way
to the Father. The apostles had just said to him, Lord, show us the way. He said, I am the way.
I am the truth and I am the life. So since they did not show the way to come to me,
the majority of them being crippled, blind and sick, that spiritually, I had to lower myself
within the guise of my humanity, which covered the fiat, which I wanted to give. I had to become
their brother. On Corinthians 9, 22, I became all things to all men in order to save some of them.
I became their brother. I associated with everybody. Look at the humility. Now, don't forget this
is God incarnate. This is just not any man. I associated with everyone to be able to teach
the first rudiments, the ABC of the Supreme Fiat. Now, to me, the ABC of the Supreme Fiat is
Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10. Here, O Israel, the Lord, your God is one Lord and you shall love the Lord,
your God with all your heart and with all your soul and with all your mind and with all your being.
Notice the word A double L all over the place. You've got to be completely committed.
And that was given at the very beginning of the journey of that people to God.
And so he said, and everything I taught, everything I did and everything I suffered was nothing but
preparing the way, preparing the kingdom and preparing the kingdom of my will. And the only
thing he could do at the time was give us that wonderful prayer that we call the Our Father,
in which he would put, he literally put on our lips, thy kingdom come, thy will be done on earth
as it is in heaven. And so the church has prayed that for two thousand years in preparation for
its fulfillment. Then he explains, as he has done many times up to now, this is the usual way with
our works. We do the minor things in preparation for the greater things. Now, actually, we do that
as well. If you want to paint your house, you first of all have to clean it up. You've got to clean
down the walls, you've got to prepare the walls, make sure that they get ready for painting and
all that. And the last thing on earth you do is painting. But you do a lot of work before you do
the painting, because if you don't do the preparatory work, you're going to absolutely waste the paint
and the time. This is the usual way with our works. We do minor things in preparation for
greater things. Did I not do the same with you? He said, at the beginning, now we're back in volume
one now. At the beginning, I certainly did not speak to you about the Supreme Fiat, nor about the
height, the sanctity which I wanted you to reach. So we're now covering the first four to six volumes.
Nor did I ever mention the greater mission that I was calling you, because in those volumes,
Louisa is a victim soul. She doesn't know until she gets to know that up in volume 11 and 12
that he's giving her a completely new mission. So what's he doing? Jesus says you have to go
through ordinary sanctity before you get into the sanctity of the divine will. And one of the
mistakes that I think people are making today is trying to jump into the sanctity of the divine
will without knowing anything about ordinary sanctity. That's not very good, you know. You're
going to have to backtrack an awful lot, because you actually need to know something about the
spiritual life. And that's why I have insisted all down the years, study the early volumes,
get everybody on their feet with regard to ordinary spirituality. And then when they come to the
divine will, they're on their feet, they can take it. And you have it here, it's not my words. Jesus
is saying it. So he said, I didn't even tell you about the greater mission I was calling you to.
I kept you as a little child to whom I delighted in teaching obedience, love of suffering, detachment
from everyone, death to your own self, you see the basics of the ordinary spiritual life.
These are the first lessons. And that's why volumes one to four I call the foundation stones
of the divine will edifice, because if you don't get that and you think you can live in the divine
will with problems of attachment, you won't get anywhere. If you think you could live in the divine
will without any love of suffering, well, how are you going to do? You won't manage at all.
If you haven't accepted reparation and you're not prepared to do reparation, you're not going
anywhere in the divine will. All those lessons are in the early volumes and they're absolutely
essential. So he said, I delighted in teaching you obedience, love of suffering, detachment from
everyone, death to your own self. You know, you can't actually live. Now live is 24 seven three six
five. You can't actually live in the divine will if the self is raining. And that's why again,
in the early volumes, we deal with the death to self problem. And as you responded to me,
the translator says, corresponded, which is not really the way we speak in ordinary English today,
as you responded to me, I rejoiced because I could see prepared in you the place in which to put my
fear. Now can't you see what is that? He's saying he has got to carve out a space in us in order to
put the fear. But there is no space if there's worldliness and selfishness and sin and attachments
and all the other stuff, there is no space for the divine will. All of that has got to be scooped out.
And so he's now going to tell us this is the way it happened in redemption as well. It's the way
God works. Everything was done for the purpose of that fiat might rain again in the creature,
just as we had issued him from our creative hands. Okay, notice this. This is very important for all
of you. We have no hurry in our works. I always remember the very first divine will
seminar we had in my house with Tony Hickey giving it to us. And he gave us all this wonderful
teaching all day. And at the end of that time, he asked, are there any questions? Now most of us
were so full up to our ears, we couldn't even think of a question. One person asked a question
and said, is there a shortcut? At that point, I just burst out laughing. It was so plainly obvious
there was a massive journey ahead of us. Somebody just wanted a shortcut. That's typical of human
beings. And that's not the way God works. God works in each one of us step by step by step.
He's like somebody building a house and it goes in brick by brick piece by piece.
And the thing is, if in some particular area, I block his movement, then the building of that
house is blocked until that problem is solved. We have no hurry in our works because we have
not only the centuries, but all eternity at our disposal. I love that. I think it's fantastic.
Therefore, we proceed at a slow pace. Have you noticed that with the divine will? The Lord is very
careful. And if you have made a move, he wants to consolidate that move, make sure he has really
conquered that little bit inside of us. And then he'll move on when he's sure that that space has
taken. And so it's slow. So you may look back after 10 years in the divine will and say, well,
I don't think I've got very far. You're not exactly a very good judge. The Lord alone is our judge.
He's the only one who knows just how much work he has already done in you. So don't be your own judge.
Therefore, we proceed at a slow pace, but for our own triumph. First we prepare,
and then we act. As I said, if you're going to paint, you first of all have to do a lot of preparation.
Nor do I have less power after returning to heaven than I would have if I continue to be on the earth.
My power is always the same. Whether I'm in heaven or on earth,
design our call and choose my mother while being in the celestial faveland. In the same way, I have
called and chosen you for the longed for fiat with the same power with which nobody can resist.
I love that nobody can resist. In other words, they call to the divine will has been quite persistent
in all of us. And you'll notice that if you even try to turn away, it's so impossible because the
alternative is so awful anyway. So he's calling and the more we respond to his call, the stronger
the call gets. It's actually quite important. So in the same way, I've called and chosen you for
the longed for fiat with the same power with which no one can resist. Even more, I tell you that in
order to obtain this, you have at your disposal greater and more important helps, I would say,
tings isn't exactly the most wonderful word to use there than my beloved mother did. Therefore,
you are more fortunate than she because she didn't have a heavenly mother to help her.
Like that's lovely. She didn't have a heavenly mother's works to help her in order to obtain
the longed for redeemer. She had only the courtage of the acts of the prophets and the patriarchs
which were much more on the human level because you're back in the Old Testament. Okay, and the
good of the Old Testament and of the great foreseen goods of the future redeemer. So blessed mother
only had the help that was available from the Old Testament and they longed for redeemer who was
coming to her that Jesus was helping her from heaven. But you, on the other hand, you have a mother.
You have all her works to help you. You have the helps, the pains and the prayers and the very
life not foreseen as with the prophets but carried out of your redeemer. The prophets could only see
things ahead of time. There are no goods nor prayers that have been done and are being done in the
church which are not with you. In other words, all the prayer of all the church of all time is with
us. I think we should remember that a little often. It's wonderful and to help you to obtain
the longed for fear. Now why does he say that specifically to Louisa? Because Louisa is the first
and the divine will was to come on the earth through her mission and through her intercession.
So when he says the prayer of the whole church is with you, it's 2,000 years of praying the
our Father. This is really wonderful. Since the primary purpose of all that was done by me and by
the queen of heaven and by all the good was the fulfillment of my will, everything is with you.
In other words, we have an enormous amount of help that was certainly not available to our blessed
mother and so we need to realize the riches that we have and we need to call upon. We also have all
the saints on our side praying for us and helping us with all the angelic choirs helping us as well.
Therefore be attentive. I will always be with you which is Joshua 1 5 and so will my mother be
always with you. You will not be alone in longing for the triumph of our will. So let's look at March
the 31st. Very wonderful message here in March the 31st. So in paragraph one entering into the
divine will is entering into God Himself. That's why you can't really be living the divine will
unless you're in union with God. My poor mind was dissolving in the divine will
and an endless light. Now that endless light is God Himself. It is the divine will. 1 John 1 5,
God is light and 1 Timothy 6 16, God dwells in unapproachable light. Okay, so an endless light
invaded the little circle of my intelligence and while it seemed that this light was as though
centralized in my mind, it could spread outside and fill the whole atmosphere penetrating even to
the heavens. It seemed as though centralized in the divinity. Now what she's noticing is that the
divine will is centralized in her on earth and in the divinity in heaven. It's the same will.
But who can say what one could feel or understand while being in that light?
One could feel the fullness of happiness. Now in the volumes leading up to this, Jesus has said
that the divine will contain the fullness of all beatitude and is the beatitude of the saints in
heaven. Nothing could penetrate into that light which might shade the joy, the beauty, the strength,
the penetration of the divine secrets and the knowledge of the supreme mysteries.
So there's an awful lot could be said about that. The Old Testament scriptures and the New Testament
scriptures both tell us that those who enter the divine will in heaven, all tears will be wiped away
that they will have the fullness of happiness. Isaiah says it and it's quoted in the New Testament
as well. I want to give you Matthew 5, 8, the pure in heart, see God, and Romans 8, 35 to 39
that literally nothing would be able to separate us from God in this wonderful experience.
So while I was swimming in that light, 1 John 1 5, I believe Jesus told me, my daughter at this
light, this dwelling which is so enchanting which knows neither sunset nor night is my will.
And for that I want to give you Revelation 21 verses 22 and 23 which we will deal with if
you come to the Revelation class. But right now I'll just simply say that in the New Jerusalem
you don't need sunlight or moonlight because God himself is the light. Everything is complete
in this light. Happiness is complete, strength, beauty, knowledge of the supreme being, everything.
The light is so endless because it's eternal. It's our will. It came out of the womb of the
divinity and it came as the heritage of man. It was given to us. It was the most beautiful
inheritance we could give him, Sam 1 21 verse 4, Revelation 22 5. It came out of our innermost being
bringing with itself a share in all of our goods to let the creature inherit them and to form him
as all beautiful and holy in the likeness of the one who created him. So in the likeness of
God is Romans 8 29 and Sam 82 verse 6 says I said you are God's all of you sons of the most high.
So what is the key that unlocks all of this beauty and glory and splendor of the first two
paragraphs? And it is that Jesus says that knowledge is the key. Now for all of you who are teaching
divine will, knowledge is the key. We've got to keep teaching this material and gradually people
will grasp but they will understand it, they will enter into it and that's it. All we have to do
is help them to understand. See then my daughter what it means to do my will and to live in it,
there is no good that exists in heaven or on earth that the divine will doesn't possess.
I want you to know them otherwise how could you love them? How could you possess them or how could
you use them in the different circumstances if you don't know them? It's terribly important.
If I don't know I have a 50 euro note in my purse then I don't think I can go down to the shop and
buy the stuff I need to buy but if I know I have this money and that it will buy it from me that's
different. It's just a simple reality that the knowledge gives. So number one if you do not know
that you have a divine strength at your disposal, sure you'd lose heart at the smallest thing.
Number two if you do not know that you possess a divine beauty you'll have the courage to be with
me in a familiar way. You will feel dissimilar from me and you will not have the audacity to
snatch from me the fiat to make a common rain on the earth. Number three if you do not know that
everything I have created is yours you won't love me in everything and you will not have the
fullness of true love and so with all the other things everything depends on the knowledge.
Now number four if you do not know all the goods which my will possesses that there is nothing
which does not belong to the divine will and which you must possess. It would happen to you as to
a poor one who was given a million oh I said 50 euros a million is different but without letting
him know that such an amount had been placed in his little hobble. The poor one who doesn't know he
has this money continues to live his poor life because he's in ignorance. His stomach is half
empty his clothes are tattered he drinks in sips and the bitterness of his poverty but if he knows
that he has a million ah he changes his fortune he turns the hobble into a palace he feeds himself
abundantly clothes himself with decency drinks the sweet tips of his richness so as many goods
as one can possess if he does not know them it is as if he doesn't have them that's as clear as daylight.
So in the next paragraph then Jesus says that we have to know and love
in order to possess to take hold of the goods of the divine will. So this is the reason so very
often that I expand your capacity. Now here's a hint for you you should ask the Lord frequently
expand my capacity to be able to take what you're giving to me. Expanded according to your wisdom
the way you know. Increase your love in me. So I expand your capacity I give you more knowledge
about my will and I make known to you everything that belongs to it. Now for this knowledge and
understanding if your mind is stuffed with all the worldly knowledge and scientific knowledge
you don't actually need then there's no room to learn about this knowledge. So we have to make room
in our intellects our memories and our wills for this knowledge. So that means putting other things
that are not so important in their own place. This must take precedence.
So in other words the Lord if you if he's to give us more knowledge there has to be room inside of
us for it. And I make known to you everything that belongs to the divine will so that you may
possess it it's not enough to just simply know that you may possess not only my will but everything
that belongs to it. Besides in order to come to reign in the soul my supreme will wants to find
its own goods its own dominion. In other words if the king comes to visit he wants to see that the
place is not actually a hovel that is some kind of a royal palace so all of this preparation has
got to be done. And the soul must make them her own so that upon coming to reign within her the
divine will may find its own dominions over which to lay its regime its command. If it does not find
heaven and earth within the soul over what can it reign? If the Lord is coming to return to reign
and he wants to reign in our souls and we don't surrender our souls to him well how is he going to
reign? He's not going to be like the enemy who will overcome you and deceive you and take possession
of you without you agreeing to it. The Lord isn't like that. Here is the necessity for which my will
wants to centralize all goods in you that you must know them you must love them you must possess them
so that being in you the divine will may find its kingdom and will dominate and rule over it.
So Louisa said afterwards I was thinking about what Jesus had told me and more than ever I could
see my littleness and I said to myself how can I centralize within myself everything that the
divine will contains. It seems to me that the more he speaks the littler I become and the more
incapable I feel and it's a very important thing for Louisa to say because all of us will have had
that experience but we might have interpreted the experience negatively. In other words how could
that happen to me? Sure I'm an absolute nobody. You know I'm a sinner I'm not a saint how can
this possibly happen to me and if we give this reaction it can be that we're actually stopping
what the Lord wants to do. Louisa correctly sees herself as incapable and a little nothing but
that's exactly what the Lord wants to use. He wants to use our nothingness but it needs to be a positive
thing and so I'll give you John 3.30 he must grow greater and I must grow smaller as John the Baptist
said. So how can this be? She said and Jesus said to her my daughter you must know that my celestial
mother was able to conceive me the eternal word within her most pure womb because she did the will
of God as God does it. There you have it there you have it there you have it there's the secret
it's to do the will of God divinely that's it. When we have the will of God inside of us
and we let the will of God do the will of God it's done divinely there's the answer and it doesn't
matter that I'm an absolute definition of a nobody it doesn't matter it's to let the divine will
act as the divine will within us I think this is brilliant. All the other prerogatives that she
possessed that is virginity and conception without original sin, sanctity and seas of grace and
everything else that she possessed were not sufficient means to be able to conceive God
now in English you don't say ah God because all these prerogatives gave her neither the immensity
nor the all-seeingness to be able to conceive God who is immense and who sees everything
and even less the fecundity to be able to receive him. In some she would have lacked the seed
of divine fecundity now watch this what is this seed watch this she would have lacked the seed
of divine fecundity but by possessing the supreme will as her own life not as something outside of
her as her own very life and by doing the will of God as God does it so doing the will of God
divinely this is the highest privilege of a human being on this planet she received the seed of
divine fecundity and with it the immensity and the all-seeingness. Wow the whole secret of doing
everything is doing the divine will as God himself does it. This paragraph gives you the answer to
everything everything I just think it's brilliant therefore in a natural way I could be conceived in
her because I lacked neither immensity nor all that belongs to my being is not incredible
so in this final paragraph that I'll do with you tonight he tells us that we have to reach the point
of actually acquiring the right to have this possession of the divine will you don't get this
overnight now this is a journey now my daughter the centralization of everything that belongs to my
will will be as though natural for you also if you arrive at doing the divine will as God himself
does it there's your secret the will of God in you and that which reigns within God himself will be
the same what is the wonder then if everything which is of God and which this will rules and preserves
and dominates it's also yours rather what is needed is that you know what belongs to the divine will
so that you may love the goods you possess and in loving them you may acquire the right of possession
so notice it's loving them that you must know them you must love them you must live the divine
will so that you can begin to take possession of them and as you do the divine will as God himself
does it then you acquire the right of possession it's absolutely incredible doing the will of God
as God does it was the highest the most substantial the most necessary point for my mother in order
to obtain the longed for Redeemer and of course it's the same for Louisa all of her other
prerogatives were the superficial part the decency the decorum that befister it's the same for you
if you want to obtain the longed for fiat you must arrive at this doing the will of God as God does
it i don't think we can improve on that i think that's the most incredible thing and please take
it slowly slowly slowly lent us beginning tomorrow please read this meditate on it ask the Lord to
bring you there and whatever blocks are inside of you just say Lord just be sovereign Lord and take
them away take the blocks away so i'm to thank you for joining me and good night god bless